and then as soon as we sing that
we read genesis 1 1-13
in the so so it's the service of the
church this is not just me and jonathan
saying this it's the service of the
church that's putting this in front of
you and saying
guys we're doing eden again but it's
going to be great this time
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
hello everybody i am back with richard
roland
and uh a lot of people were really
fascinated by our last video on
groundhog day and how it was related to
the feast of the presentation of the
lord and so richard had the great idea
to maybe look actually at the four major
winter feasts of the church
how they are related to light and how
they are in a way a kind of fulfillment
of the the jewish feast of hanukkah
and so richard go ahead start us off and
uh i'll follow yeah so um
something i was telling you before right
before we hit record right is that the
the feast of the presentation of the
lord or the meeting of the lord of the
temple or the purification of the
blessed virgin mary aka groundhog day
right these are all names that have been
used
for this this particular observance uh
that it's really the book end right of
of the of the kind of the whole winter
cycle of the church and this is
something that gets lost nowadays i
think sometimes
because uh in western liturgics uh there
has been
kind of this division of like sacred
time and ordinary time or like the
paschal cycle and then secular time you
know something like that right so
um so it's like all the really important
events are like bunched up between
christmas and posca or christmas and
pentecost and then there's like this big
swath of the year
that just doesn't have a whole lot of
big stuff going on liturgically but
actually this is not the case in the
medieval
church uh sir it's still not the case in
eastern orthodoxy today in eastern
orthodoxy of course as you know we have
the 12 great feasts
and the 12 great feasts are kind of
spaced all throughout the year and
together they they sort of bring us into
and help us participate in the life of
christ and of his mother and the whole
story of redemption
so i wanted to actually start though by
reading a little something from the
venerable bead
and the reason bead was a very important
anglo-saxon monk and scholar at the time
that he was living
in the 8th century he was probably
the most well-educated person in europe
um and uh which is funny because he's
sort of like off here on the on the
fringe yeah he's often you know on the
side there yeah
but um
he writes pretty extensively about
the whole uh the symbolism and the
connection between
the
you could you could say like the
the astronomical cycle of the year right
and then the
uh or the solar cycle of the year and
then the uh the christian year and the
relationship between these two things
which beads sees as not arbitrary so
this is what he says he says it is
fitting that just as the sun at that
point in time first assumed power over
the day so he's talking about the vernal
equinox or the feast of the annunciation
which actually is tomorrow from when we
are recording this we're recording this
on the 24th of march right
um
uh
first assume power of the day and then
the moon and stars power of the night so
now to kano to connote the joy of our
redemption the day should first equal
night in length and then the full moon
should suffuse the night with light so
this is talking about uh like the
possible full moon and the past and the
you know ecclesial equinox and all this
very complicated
calculus
for calculating the date of easter the
date of pasca be saying you know so at
the beginning of time you've got the sun
to rule the day and the moon to rule the
night and now because this is the
enunciation right or you know this is
the beginning of when the light comes
into the world there's there's once
again like a perfect balance between
light and darkness in the full moon and
yeah the
full moon in the sun yeah so it says
this is for the sake of a certain
symbolism because this created sun
which lights up all the stars signifies
the true and eternal light which
lighteth every man that cometh into the
world while the moon and stars which
shine not with their own light as they
say but with an adventitious light
borrowed from the sun so by the way uh
even even back then people knew that the
moon reflected the light
yeah yeah
uh
suggests the body of the church as a
whole and each individual saint right so
this really beautiful symbolism of the
moon and stars and of course
we all know that stars and planets are
angels right so
you know he's beat is just like
by now we all know it's like you can say
that without controversy anymore i know
i know it's great it's amazing great
yeah
these cape these capable of being
illumined but not of illuminating know
how to accept the gift of heavenly grace
but not how to give it and in the
celebration of the supreme solemnity it
was necessary that christ precede the
church which cannot shine save through
him
observing the possible seasons this is
what he says observing the possible
season is not meaningless for it is
fitting that through it the world's
salvation both be symbolized and come to
pass
right so so what what he's literally
saying
is
the correlation between
the vernal equinox right the beginning
of spring
and pasca
you know annunciation pasca that whole
you know
church
that he's saying that relationship is
not arbitrary it's it's it's fitting
it's uh this is a really important word
in latin right this this idea of
something is fitting it's proper it's
seemly
it's the way that things should be
and so this is the thing you have to
sort of say you know people
uh people kind of get hung up sometimes
on uh as we all know we all know people
who get hung up on this you know oh well
maybe maybe christmas is just like
a thinly veiled version of some pagan
winter festival right that was about the
dying sun coming back to life on all
these different things
and but the the thing to understand is
that uh
it is that there's no canadian geometry
jonathan pedro do you know this do you
know this phrase the same oh i've never
heard that before okay so uh
it's uh oh you mean that it's a
universal truth like yeah it's right
right it's something that is gonna
happen you're gonna have a feast at the
solstice because it has nothing to do
with imitating eats or whatever it's
just naturally
it's the only pushes itself on us that
this is an important moment in in our
story right and it's it's one of those
ways like you can understand it it's
just like the ripple effects throughout
time of christ's incarnation and his
birth right
um
i think one of the most potent arguments
for christ being actually born in
december and i'm sure somebody out there
will come after me about this but
whatever
um
is is just the fact that everyone knows
something important happens right right
around december 25th everyone knows that
everyone in every culture knows that
right
so um i say all that to say uh why is
this part of universal history right
universal history isn't just here's a
narrative that goes from point a to
point b
and then we try to like write ourselves
or fit ourselves into the narrative but
actually
it's a means of you could say it's like
a more ancient more old world more
medieval understanding of time in which
we're actually participating
in
the story of salvation in the life of
christ and of his mother but we're
participating through
the natural world
right and so and so
that allows this understanding of time
not to just be something that we larp
not to just be something that like oh
today is march the 24th i guess since we
don't know when jesus was born i'm going
to celebrate christmas today like there
are technically people who will argue
that you can do that but practically
speaking nobody does and it's because we
all know things don't really work that
way yeah yeah and there's and i think
that it really is once you start to
understand symbolism and how
you know the world and
reveals itself in meaning that it's
necessarily
so you can't avoid meaning you can't for
example the idea that let's say the
equinox or that the solstices don't have
meaning is so completely insane you
actually have more light
in the world like the fact that that
doesn't have meaning you can go outside
at seven and like here let's say i can
go outside at seven i can still do some
work there's still a sense you know
there's you can feel it in your skin
that like the world is coming alive so
it's so it's so deeply intuitive the
idea that that doesn't have meaning and
that the world of meaning wouldn't
participate in that experience
is misunderstanding how
misunderstanding how meaning works and
misunderstanding how we experience the
world so
yeah so what i wanted to do in today's
video is actually to shed a little light
as it were a little yeah on on on the on
the winter festivals of the church right
because we typically think of christmas
and i think part of the reason so many
people i mean i had so many people come
up and talk to me or just reach out to
me randomly from all over the internet
about the groundhog day video because it
sort of blew their mind that there was
this connection between this weird
little relic of like american culture
and then
and then you know an actual feast of the
church uh but what i want to do is kind
of expand on that a little bit and show
how groundhog day is actually um there
are these what we could say four winter
festivals of light in the ancient church
and the way that these four winter
festivals of light actually sort of come
together and expand on this idea or sort
of
sort of show the show the christological
reality behind the idea of hanukkah
right and so actually putting this
material together started with a
question that somebody asked actually
two people in one week asked me this
question
and then the following somebody else
asked me that questions like three times
in two weeks somebody said well
why don't christians celebrate hanukkah
shouldn't we just celebrate hanukkah and
if we've got jewish listeners out there
out there who do celebrate hanukkah
great i mean you know i'm not
i'm i have no beef with hanukkah right
but but i do believe obviously that uh
that christianity is true
and that orthodoxy is is is true and
that all of the sort of the themes that
we find in the celebration of hanukkah
right this theme of the restoration of
light and then this theme of the
restoration of the temple
uh we actually fight all of these things
uh being fulfilled not just in one
feast but in four feasts so it's like so
my answer to that is sort of like i'll
do you one better let's celebrate
hanukkah four times four times so yeah
but it's important to understand that as
christians we understand that all of the
old testament and all of the old feasts
all of the laws
culminate into christ and so it's not
that they stop existing it's that they
find a type of fulfillment which
actually sometimes transforms them
sometimes flips them does all these
things with these with these rules with
these stories but they because they are
but they are fulfilled in christ and so
the the literary the christian
liturgical year is actually coherent
with the ancient jewish liturgical year
it's just that it is re-seen a recast
in the story of the incarnation and we
see this in the words of christ himself
uh because of course quite famously in
the gospel according to saint john
christ celebrates hanukkah
in the gospel according to saint john is
called the feast of the rededication
right but that's what it is
he said he goes to the temple and he
goes to celebrate this feast and it's in
the context of that feast that he very
famously says i am the light of the
world right right so he's going to this
festival of light and he's saying
actually i'm the light
right and uh and so what's he doing he's
filling that feast with himself
and the whole experience of the church
since that moment
uh that eventually develops into these
winter festivals of light is
you could say it's an extended attempt
to expose it that to understand what
does it mean for christ to be the light
of the world
and so many people will know but i think
it's probably a good idea nonetheless
to just tell people what hanukkah is
like what the origin is and what the the
basic premise of the feast is so
hanukkah is a jewish feast uh it's not
one that was actually commanded by the
mosaic law but it was instituted later
following the victory of the maccabean
heroes against the armies of antiochus
iv epiphanies
um and so the maccabean heroes
reconsecrated the second temple in
jerusalem which had been looted and
desecrated
and they did this in an eight day very
important number there in an eight day
ceremony which culminated in the
resumption of the daily sacrifices which
had ceased at that point for a period of
about three and a half years
and um as an actual feast celebrated by
the jewish people hanukkah is first
mentioned
uh in the first century right around the
time of christ so it actually seems that
when christ went to celebrate it it was
probably maybe a somewhat new liturgical
celebration yeah
um
and uh the
original
story of hanukkah you know we've we've
all kind of probably heard the story
um i think they even tell it on like an
episode of friends or something back in
the day right it's like it's like a
major part of you know pop culture
living in america you probably sort of
know there's the story about they didn't
have enough oil but then the oil burned
for eight days that's a that's a fairly
late medieval version of the story of
hanukkah which which is sort of the
thing that people remember now but the
original you know if you go back and
look at uh writings from around the time
of christ and up to about the sixth
fifth or sixth century
what you actually find is that the the
story of hanukkah the celebration has to
do not with the restoration of the
menorah light in the holy place but
actually with the uh the restoration of
the sacrificial fires which they're
always supposed to keep lit and then
we're un where we're we're not lit three
and a half years and then sort of the
this flame is miraculously revived from
the ashes okay um which is very
important to understanding because the
theme of hanukkah is really about
the you could say the restoration of the
temple right it's the reconsecration of
this space
um
where god can be properly worshipped
yeah and obviously this is a very
biblical idea it is dare i say a very
orthodox idea um
the restoration of a of an earthly
temple
uh is an idea that no orthodox christian
or and and hopefully no christian of any
sort
should despise right you know if if the
turks gave us back hagia sophia tomorrow
right i would be on an airplane right
you know to you know to be there
participated in its reconciliation right
exactly you know so so this is not a bad
theme however
it is more perfectly fulfilled and the
restoration of what i would say is the
temple of the cosmos
right which is which is kind of the
theme so that's what these four winter
feasts do they take this restoration of
the temple and they turn it into a
restoration not just up one earthly
building in jerusalem but actually the
restoration of the temple with man at
its center as the image and as the as
the high priest
so
that's why we can understand the
relationship both with
the solstice which is the let's say the
re-lighting of the sacred fire in the
sky you know where the light is going
down down down and then it's re-lit we
can also understand the incarnation as
the moment where
the new temple is
re-dedicated where in the darkness of
the cave this temple appears almost it's
the secret part of it that appears and
is going to start to reveal itself as
the story kind of continues yeah so if
you're familiar with the feast of the
church you'll know uh that actually you
can already see the theme of the temple
emerging just in the names
of the two of the feasts that bookend
this for the cycle of four winter feasts
so the four winter feasts are
uh the entrance of the theotokos into
the temple uh which in the western
liturgical tradition is also called the
presentation of mary yeah um and then
so that's
one sort of bookend and then as you move
into these four feasts they they form a
sort of chiastic structure so you have
mary presented at the temple and then
you have the nativity and then you have
uh theophany or epiphany and then you
have the presentation of the lord at the
temple right the meaning of the lord of
the temple the presentation of jesus
cannamus
uh purification of the blessed virgin
mary whatever you want to call it
um
and so
this begins with uh
uh
so these two these two feasts on the
book end you know they're very similar
in their focus and even in liturgically
they're the way that they're observed is
very similar
and um and of course the gospel reading
for the meaning of the lord at the
temple
ends with saint simmy and the god
receiver for telling the sufferings of
the mother of god at the foot of the
cross
so you can even see how this whole set
of feasts is bookended by the mother of
god
she becomes you could say the container
for the mystery
just in this very much the same way she
actually bookends the entire christian
year in the east uh which begins with
her nativity in september and then ends
with her door mission in august
um so and just as an aside in the
western liturgical tradition the
subsequent feasts of the nativity of
mary the holy name of mary which is a
western feast and then the presentation
of mary exactly parallel christmas the
feast of the holy name of jesus which is
the western version of the circumcision
and then the presentation of our lords
so i'm just saying all that say there
are various angles that we could study
these feasts from
um for my purposes i'm going to just
talk about the tradition of the eastern
orthodox church because it's what i know
and have experienced but i do want to go
on record as saying in the western
liturgical tradition that these winter
feasts are also present and they also
manifest in some really beautiful and
interesting structures
so
uh to talk real quick about the entrance
of the theotokos into the temple this
feast begins the very first
hymn for the feast says today let us the
faithful dance for joy singing to the
lord with psalms and hymns
venerating his hallowed tabernacle the
living ark that contained the word who
cannot be contained
for she a young child in the flesh is
offered in wondrous fashion to the lord
and with rejoicing zacharias the great
high priest receives her as the dwelling
place of god
so this is the major theme of the feast
which is introduced right at the very
beginning of vespers and that is the
coming of the new and living ark into
the temple of god now it should be noted
and people who have watched the
universal history series will know that
the ark has been missing from the temple
for quite some time
there are different culprits
who might be responsible for this come
on richard we know where the ark is i
know where they are you're right you're
right um
for several hundred years now there's
been no arc in the jerusalem temple and
this is something to which both
scripture so this is in the book is
mentioned the fact that the ark is
absent is mentioned in second maccabees
uh which if you're
an orthodox christian or a roman
catholic so the majority of the
christian world that's in your bible
um and then also there are also
eyewitness accounts like those of pompey
the great uh that talk about you know
walking into the whole most holy place
and there's nothing there's nothing
there right
um we know from archaeology and history
that there were many arcs in the ancient
world and i think they actually talked
about this a little bit on a recent
episode of lord of spirits
uh but to understand what an arc is it's
essentially a ritual test chest
which functions both as a reliquary so
it holds items that are sacred to the
cult of the god
and then also a ritual seat
um
of the god himself right and these
chests were usually carried on poles
they're usually overlaid with gold and
crucially they usually have a lid that
uh bears the image of the deity
uh so a good example of this if you look
up the uh you can just google like the
the anubis chest
uh this is from the
uh the the tomb of king tut and the
valley of the kings and if you look up a
picture of this chest it looks very
similar to the ark of the covenant um in
fact it even has cherubim you know with
the wings on it but in this case they're
on the side not not the top but it has
the cherubim right and then on the very
top obviously an important difference is
it has an idol of the god anubis on top
right
so when god commands moses to make an
ark and shows him the pattern for doing
this you know to to you know great exact
detail and measurements he's not asking
moses to make something he's never seen
before
what's unique about the ark are his
contents which prefigure christ and his
mother
and you can you know consult you know
almost any church father writing about
this subject you know we'll we'll talk
about this
um and then it's lit and of course the
important thing about a slit is that the
lid bears not a depiction of the god of
israel for at this point israel was not
allowed or able to depict their god but
rather bears two guarding cherubim right
and the cherubim are sort of the throne
they carry or guard the throne of the
deity so the message of moses's ark was
clear
this box is the throne of the god of
israel
whom the hebrews cannot depict
and what we see in the old testament is
that where the ark goes
so goes the presence of god and actually
for the feast of the of the of the
presentation of the theotokos of the
temple all of the old testament readings
are focused on the ark and they're
focused on what happens when the ark
goes somewhere
and um exodus chapter four uh uh third
kingdom seven and eight
and uh the third reading from ezekiel 43
and 44 obviously very famously uh
solidifies this relationship between
mary and the temple where we see the
theotokos as being the new temple as
being the eastern gate through which
only the messiah can pass and by the way
this is a really ancient patristic
understanding of this passage
um
that's the most important aspect of her
is that to understand that she is
the arc in the context of the
incarnation but then she also represents
not just that she physically is the ark
but that also we as the church will
become the arc that we as individuals
will become something akin to the ark
and she is the the let's say the place
where all that comes together into one
person who became the vehicle for the
incarnation right and so of course every
time that the ark is brought into the
well when it was brought into the
tabernacle in exodus and then when it
was brought into the temple
in uh uh uh second kings or first kings
um
in each of those cases
the what happens the holy spirit right
the glory of god fills the temple right
it's like nobody can even begin there
because it's too much right
and this never happened in the second
temple the glory of god had never filled
it in which in the way that it filled
the tabernacle of meeting or the temple
of solomon but the tradition of the
church is that
the uh when mary entered the temple as a
young girl that the holy spirit filled
her
as the new ark in a tangible way and
i'll just say here as an aside people
will say things like oh well that could
never have happened because they would
never have allowed a woman into the
temple building listen no one is saying
this is an ordinary circumstance that's
such a silly argument to me um it's like
it's like here's a miraculous thing well
miracles don't happen so that you know
it's okay whatever but um
uh but the tradition of the church is
that when she entered the holy spirit
filled her as the new ark
and this way for the first time in a
tangible way the holy spirit actually
entered the holy of holies the place
where the ark was supposed to be kept
and this is why it is really significant
in our tradition to emphasize the fact
that that she was brought into the holy
of holies uh something that was missing
from the second temple even after it was
reconsecrated was this presence of god
with the ark and now that's been
restored so again if our whole theme is
the restoration of the temple as a place
where god can dwell that's the theme of
this first feast
yeah and i would say it's like to say to
people like protestants that are
watching this who struggle with the fact
of this like they struggle with the idea
or whatever i mean fine you'll get there
in time but in the meantime notice the
important analogies and the important
typology that is being brought about
which is absolutely and and completely
uh true and it is necessary for us to
understand the significance of the
incarnation and what it means for us
even as a church
yeah so mary becomes a literal arc right
um
uh she
uh and when she does this she's she
fulfills the you know the prophecy of of
david in psalm 44 uh or psalm 43. um you
know when it says that virgins shall be
brought to the king after her her
companion shall be brought unto thee
with gladness and rejoicing they shall
be brought and they shall be brought
into the temple of the king so this is
in the psalms david prophesies that
there's going to be this woman who's
going to be a queen of israel and she's
going to be brought into the temple
this does not happen
anywhere in the old testament yeah um
and for no one before her was this ever
true but the tradition of the church
does record that mary was accompanied by
young women of her people going before
her with candles so there's like another
kind of connection to candlemas
and that she's brought into the temple
of the king
right um and elsewhere we see her in the
hymns of this feast referred to as an
acceptable sacrifice
um that she was brought into the holy of
police because she was a sacrifice
acceptable to god
so the idea is that she becomes a
literal arc her womb carries not merely
relics but god himself and on a very
literal level her lap becomes a throne
on which christ sits yeah and that's in
terms of iconography it's really people
need to understand the basic image one
of the basic images of christianity is
called the throne of wisdom and you see
the mother of god sitting
as she's sitting on a throne but she
herself becomes a throne and christ is
sitting on her lap centrally usually
with his head on her heart and so she
becomes the ark that surrounds him and
then he is the glory sitting on the ark
yeah yeah so this kind of sets up this
whole theme with the restoration of the
temples and the orthodox church we
celebrate this feast in november
um just a little bit into the advent
faster the nativity fast for us
and this is the first of the really the
four great winter celebrations now the
next one is obviously nativity
or christmas
which most of us think we probably know
a lot about because christmas is one of
the few surviving things in fact
oh here it is
hold on
um this is a great book uh by eamon
duffy it's called the stripping of the
altars if you want to know what was
christianity like in england before the
reformation and why was it awesome this
is a great this is a great book um but
one of the things he talks about in here
is that uh uh
christmas is kind of the only survival
in many cases
of of a lot of the old church year even
even easter especially
growing up evangelical right we never we
sort of never really knew what to do
around easter in fact i remember one
one year
uh something had come up and and we
didn't have the easter you know the
easter thing like the cantata or the
play or whatever ready in time so we
just decided we'll just celebrate easter
a month later like nobody really knows
when it happened so let's just celebrate
him up later you know it's
it's not great
um
but uh but somehow christmas christmas
has has held on a lot longer for many of
us
um and uh
but
there are some themes that have to do
with the restoration of the temple and
this theme of the sort of the revival of
light or the preservation of the light
in the darkness
and the connection of all those things
which which are maybe not obvious to us
now
so
um
the troparia of the four feast so like
the day before christmas christmas eve
we sang mary once with aged joseph
went to be taxed in bethlehem for they
were of the lineage of david and she
bore in her womb the fruit that had not
been sown
which is a great that's a great line the
time of the birth of the birth was at
hand and there was no room in the end
but the caved the cave proved a fair
place for the queen
christ is born that he may raise up the
image
that before was fallen and the two
things i want to focus on here are first
of all the idea of the cave right and i
know that you've done some great videos
of this on your channel
uh but but it's very important that it
happened in a cave which is not said
anywhere in scripture yeah and yet of
course pretty much everyone today if you
ask them they'd say oh well of course
you know they didn't have enough wood to
build a stable or something like that
you know like like the economics of the
situation are the most important reason
that it have it happened in a cave right
but usually like even movies and things
like that will show as being in a cave
and i think it's because we do know deep
down that this is a very important
symbolism
of the cave right the cave is the womb
the cave is the grave and the grave as a
womb right which is what it is for
christ and the connection of all those
things but the other thing to mention
here is this idea that christ is born
that he may raise up again the image
that before was fallen
uh we get the we get an extended gloss
on this with another troparia that says
made ready o bethlehem for eden hath
been opened to all prepare o ephrathah
for the tree of life hath blossomed
forth in the cave from the virgin for
who womb did appear as a spiritual
paradise in which is planted the divine
plant
whereof eating we shall live and not die
as adam verily christ shall be born
raising the image that fell of old
so both of these hymns take us all the
way back to the beginning they take us
back to genesis
back to eden
and we can think about the fact that in
genesis after our first parents are cast
out of the garden there's a cherub who's
set to guard the entrance to paradise
with a flaming sword
uh and this is way worse than just being
banned from like a nice place like you
know like like just be sorry you can't
come back to colorado springs yeah yeah
um
in the ancient near east this word
paradise means a walled garden um if you
listen to the lord of spirits you'll
know quite well that that the whole idea
is that god lives in a garden at the top
of a mountain everyone in the ancient
world
near east knew this believed this and uh
um and actually on the orthodox arts
journal andrew gould has a great series
of articles they're from a few years
back but i really recommend people go
and read them uh where he gets really
really specific into the relationship
between ancient paradise gardens
and then the layout of our orthodox
churches today which are sort of
reminded uh
intended to remind us that when we stand
together in church we're actually
participating in heavenly worship we're
in paradise
and so in the ancient world at the
conclusion of the construction of a
temple
they would place the uh the god in the
center of the temple and in ancient
egypt they did this through something
called the uh
this ritual was performed by these group
of priests who were called the sem
priests they were these leopard-skinned
robes i don't know why that's the detail
that stuck out in my mind
and they would perform a ceremony called
the opening of the mouth by the way they
also did this when they would mummify
someone so you know the idea
of of like the dead person becoming like
a you know like an image or like an idol
um
and uh this basically is the idea is to
imbue the statue of the god with the
spirit of the god or the person it
depicts and therefore allowing them to
act as surrogates for the person who
commissioned the image
and um
uh what numerous biblical scholars
obviously if you're watching symbolic
world you probably are familiar with
father stephen de young he's got a great
article on this called man is the image
of god in reverse that you can go and
read about i'm not going to read
everything from that but the whole idea
here
is that is this idea of god creating a
temple for himself in the cosmos that's
what eden is supposed to be that's what
paradise is supposed to be and then you
have man
at the center
of eden at the center of paradise we're
told that he placed man in the midst of
the garden is supposed to be there as
the image and then also as the high
priest so he performs this priestly
function of naming the animals right
this is really essential to
understanding like why are we here on
this planet like this you know it's
really cosmic essential stuff
um and then of course what happens is
that the image falls over the image
becomes
sullied
right and so man can no longer take that
place of priest in creation and actually
what we find is any time we attempt to
do i shouldn't say any time but most of
the time when we attempt to like take
dominion what it actually looks like is
is you know disaster like we kill things
we we oppress things we destroy our
environment we do all these things
because we're just you know the image is
fallen you know we are supposed to take
dominion but not in that way right
um and so you can see the process of
pagan temple
dedication reversed in genesis right and
that's a foreshadowing of the
incarnation um
and uh
so you've got eden as a temple the
temple is you know moses tabernacle and
solomon's temple they're supposed to be
icons of eden and so what we find in the
mystical truth of the feast of christmas
is that the cave which is probably not a
very glamorous place
uh becomes the container for the mother
of god who is herself the new spiritual
paradise in other words she's the new
eden
thereby opening eden to all
uh so in this new eden there's a new
divine plant there's a new tree of life
which is somehow the cross but is also
christ and it's the exact opposite of
the fruit that brings death to adam so
in the new tabernacle of creation we see
christ raising up the image of god
raising up human nature and making it
possible for there to be true worship
and communion again why because there's
a new fruit to eat and there's a new
priest
to give you that fruit
yeah and you can see it for people who
are interested if you look at an icon of
the last judgment for example
you will see that on the right side of
christ at the bottom of the icon there
is an image of paradise
and in the inn you see usually at the
door saint peter sometimes in saint paul
coming to the door of paradise and the
cherub is there the chair is going to
let them in and then in paradise is
usually an image of the virgin sitting
on a throne it's not just because she's
in paradise but it's because she is
paradise
you know she is the the place where the
garden was restored and you know the
tree of life was restored in the person
of christ and in the cross so you know
it's
it's it's important to understand that
in for ancient thinking these things
really coalesce yeah and that there is
absolutely no problem in seeing all of
these things coming together like in the
hymn that richard uh
richard recited and something i'm really
keen to try to to communicate here it is
it's hard to think about exactly how to
say this but
there is
you could say that that there there are
two extremes that you want to avoid
and one would be just like getting the
super
cosmic vision of everything that's so
large it stops being specific
right um and so i know there are you
know some people out there who'd be like
oh these are great ideas and
other religions have them too and things
like so it must all be true right
um
or or or just sort of you know that that
that attitude of
well this here's an idea that's so high
you know that it has in other words like
it's all it's all heaven and no earth
it's all spirit and nobody
that it doesn't actually matter when we
celebrate christmas or it doesn't
actually matter what we celebrate easter
right or or the worst version of that
would be because i know that this
happened i don't actually need to
celebrate anything at all
because in my head like i already know
what happened right
the other thing that we want to avoid is
being so particular in our celebration
of these things
that we can't see their cosmic
significance and the way that they
actually fill our lives now this is the
important thing about
we're talking about like a medieval view
of time or history
and this is which is kind of what this
universal history thing has evolved into
is we've had these discussions and as
i'm you know sort of mulling over this
book idea in my mind and things like
this is uh
they weren't satisfied to say oh well
now that i've become a christian i guess
there is this noah guy right what
they're doing is they're looking at that
table of nations
yeah genesis and they're saying
well where do we fit in where where
where do our people come into the story
right
and so
here in this feast of christmas right
you see the theme of hanukkah which
originally has this very specific
historical context
and it's made universal that christ in
his miraculous incarnation and birth
accomplishes the perfect union of heaven
and earth he restores human nature to
its rightful place
made in the image of god or as the image
of god and in the process
he doesn't restore just a temple at
jerusalem but he restores the temple of
the cosmos the temple of creation yeah
which is eden which is paramount yeah
paradise is the cosmic temple it's
important to understand that the
jerusalem temple or the tabernacle were
surrogates
for
eden for the garden if you don't
understand that you won't understand the
structure of eden you won't understand
the structure of the garden why there's
a cherub where there's all these things
that are basically just representations
of the garden of eden right so we need
to be able to understand that in christ
these symbolisms will start will be
you'll see in the hymns like they they
cross over and they join together and
there's references to all the different
levels uh as this is happening so that
was exactly what i wanted to mention
next is that if you look at the hymns
for the feast they just pull all of
these different levels of understanding
together just in such a beautiful
here's the thing about byzantine
homography i'm not going to say it's as
catchy
as like western hymns or like you know
praise choruses or whatever kids kids
are doing these days um you know your
your christian raps and your whatever
you know it might not be as catchy as
all that however i don't understand
youth culture however um
it's so beautiful it's so precise and
it's so so like poetically rich
which is why i think it's sort of like
it transcends
whatever the whatever's in vogue at the
moment right it transcends that and will
continue to endure
beyond that you know what even when all
of your raps are are you know in the
dustbin of history you know
um so so there's this so there's this
this uh hymn at the vespers for the
feast of the nativity
which is the middle wall of the
partition has been destroyed it's
talking about the veil
being opened the flaming sword turns
back
the cherubim withdraw from the tree of
life
and i partake of the delight of paradise
from which i was cast out through
disobedience
and then as soon as we sing that
we read genesis 1 1-13
in the so so it's the service of the
church this is not just me and jonathan
saying this it's the service of the
church that's putting this in front of
you and saying
guys we're doing eden again but it's
going to be great this time right yeah
and it's and it is a cosmic restoration
and also a reawakening of the
significance of man you know
in in christ and so it all the the
different the personal level you know
the social and the cosmic level come
together and so and it's what's great
about already with the two feats that
you can see as you can see there's a
there's a logic of
of i've mentioned this before where
before light comes darkness you could
say or before the answer of heaven comes
the tohu bohu becomes this emptiness and
void which is in a way a calling it's
like asking to be filled it's a it's a
question that is looking to be answered
so you can see in the setup of the feast
where you know the darkness comes before
the dawn right this darkest moment
appears as the space so we have to
we have to prepare the space and then
once the space is prepared that's when
the glory of god then descends on the
ark which has been prepared for it to
come and so you have the presentation of
the virgin and then you have nativity
and the the logic of it makes complete
sense yeah
and so that's a great way to think about
this because you sort of have the
let's say the going in
which is what these first two fees are
if it's a chiastic structure you have
the going in and then you have the
coming out right with these next two
feasts so the the going in is like the
the holy space is being prepared and
then the next two are the revelation of
the light exactly
yeah so you've got theophany which is
the next one we'll talk about obviously
there's a lot going on in theophany the
very first thing that we hear about
theophany in the church year practically
speaking is
is this this theme of warfare right um
make radio river jordan for behold
christ our god draws near to be baptized
by john that he may crush with his
divinity the invisible heads of the
dragons in thy waters which is a cool
best i mean it's the best thing and this
is
but i mean this is the thing and of
course this is this is uh this reference
back to psalm 73 in the septuagint um
this you know these dragons in the
waters these demonic powers the exorcism
of the cosmos right also one of the main
major themes of the baptismal service
um
and uh you know because yahweh the god
of israel is the one who breaks the
heads of the dragons in the waters right
which is what the psalmist says yeah um
and of course we showed that on the icon
of the feast you can
you can find lots of stuff out there
about this now which is a great thing
you you this father stephen young has
some stuff i'm sure you've done some
videos yeah i've talked about that yeah
so uh but the other thing that's going
on there right is the theme of
illumination or the revelation of light
right yeah we have to understand it as
because we often tend to think of the
baptism as the going down in the water
right which actually corresponds to the
first part of these two pizzas it's like
this is the going down but now what
we're talking about mostly in theophany
is the coming out of the water where
christ is coming out of the cave and
yeah you have to understand the bottom
the bottom of the water is as equivalent
to the cave itself so christ comes out
of the waters and then the holy spirit
comes down and it's a it's a recreation
of heaven and earth like everything gets
revealed in terms of what in terms of
the new structure you could say so this
is what this is what is how this is in
terms of light this is what is most
important that's why some of the images
might confuse people sometimes with
theophany because you have all these
images of baptism but then you have all
these images of light but it makes sense
if you understand it as
christ has gone down in the waters is
now coming up and you hear the voice of
god revealing the logos to the world and
that light and the revelation of the
logos is what is going on yeah it i mean
that's that's the whole reason that in
the christian tradition baptism is
referred to as illumination
right so i mean the baptismal service is
fresh on my mind i love going to
baptisms
um like if you get to go i mean we have
a lot of uh we're going through sort of
a baby boom at my parish right now so we
go to lots of baptisms and that's great
and of course we just had one in our
family for my daughter
and uh
but the baptismal service i mean it's
great because like every time you go to
a baptism it's like a refresher course
on your own baptism right
and uh and yeah that's the whole theme
throughout baptism is is this theme of
illumination right the word neophyte
originally meant
uh and really still means somebody who's
been recently illumined
right and so and to to kind of your
point about about needing to understand
this because it does have the going in
portion and the coming out is that every
one four of these feasts if you were to
look at them closely you would see that
they actually they're it's a fractal
it's actually true for all all the great
feasts of the church
every great feast of the church so
annunciation is coming up tomorrow if
you look closely at annunciation you'll
see in it
every other feast right is is in there
pasca is in there christmas is in there
right the the passion is in there right
it's all in enunciation um and that's
true obviously everything's sort of
gathered up into posca so they're all
sort of like fractals of each other
um
and and uh yeah so so baptism
the big focus right um of theophany
other than spiritual warfare the big
focus is is of illumination right so we
have christ being himself the bestower
of light jesus needs not to be baptized
but in the flesh he descends into the
streams of the jordan wishing to give
light to those in darkness let us go
eagerly in faith to meet him so the idea
is he's bringing the light kind of down
to us right
cena from the syrian has this wonderful
idea of sort of christ going down and
leaving the garment of light
at the bottom of the waters right so
that when we are baptized we kind of go
down in and bring it up and get it on
right
i love that so much
um
so
now
the the connection to the our master
theme right which is the restoration of
the temple this might not seem like
immediately clear but we need to
remember that both the original occasion
of hanukkah as well as its more common
name in the ancient world was the
festival of lights
and the occasion of this feast this is
referred to in john chapter 10 uh of
as the feast of the dedication
was to celebrate this
dedication of the jerusalem temple
following this military victory and by
the time of christ it's already known as
the festival of lights
and this is again tied to originally to
the miraculous rewriting of the altar
fires that later story of the oil that
lasts for eight days it's like a later
kind of accretion but you can understand
why it still symbolically participates
in that
basic it's very similar
it's just
yeah it's slightly different but
basically yes when i say stupid modern
academic things like that's a later
accretion like i'm not i'm not actually
saying i'm not actually saying like it's
a it's not amazing you're still you
still think it's impossible yeah i mean
it's you can admit that maybe it's a
later legend yeah but it perfectly
participates in the overall symbolism
you know so i'm you know i'm fine with
it yeah not that anyone cares but i'm
fine with it but um it's
it's in the context right of the
celebration in john chapter 10 that of
course christ declares i am the light of
the world right and so what christ is
doing
is he's offering himself as the exegesis
of this essentially old testament feast
and also perfectly clarifying its deep
connection to theophany
so on theophany the church commemorates
and participates in christ conquest of
the demonic powers which have enslaved
mankind and infested the cosmos
and then the result of that is the light
which as saint john says enlightens
every man that comes into the world so
in theophany we see the cosmos once
again becomes capable of being offered
up to god in this act of thanksgiving
with man as the as the priest of
creation and the image of god which is
restored
right so that brings us to the meeting
of lord of the temple which we talked
about uh quite a bit last time
and i just want to maybe spend a little
bit of time um because i don't actually
i should have gone back and listened to
the video again because i don't remember
how much we said about this last time
um
did we talk about the the eucharistic
focus of the video uh in the video the
eucharistic focus of that feast well
we're gonna talk about it i think so i
don't know okay yeah i don't think we
got to it because we were trying to talk
about uh groundhog groundhog day right
um
so the the hymnography and the
iconography of the orthodox church for
this feast
focuses particularly on the handoff of
the christ child from the theotokos to
saint symbian
um and when he does this we're sort of
deliberately reminded of another time a
prophet of god met yahweh the god of
israel in the temple so in isaiah
chapter 6 which we read at the vespers
of this feast we have the story of
isaiah if you don't know it this is
isaiah the prophet he comes to the
temple and he has this mystical vision
of god seated in glory in the temple it
says in a year that king uzziah died i
saw the lord sitting on a throne high
and lifted up and the train of his robe
filled the temple above it's to the
seraphim each one had six wings with two
he covered his face and with two he
covered his feet and with two he flew
and one cried to another and said holy
holy holy is the lord of hosts the whole
earth is full of his glory
and the post of the door were shaken by
the voice of him who cried out and the
house was filled with smoke and so i
said isaiah said woe is me for i am
undone because i am a man of unclean
lips and i dwell in the midst of a
people of unclean lips for my eyes have
seen the king of the lord of hosts then
one of the seraphim flew to me having in
his hand a live coal which he had taken
from the tongs with tongs from the altar
and he touched my mouth with it and said
behold this has touched your lips your
iniquity is taken away and your sin is
purged
and i read the whole thing a because
it's probably my favorite thing in the
bible i mean
you you get a different answer from me
maybe depending on
what we're talking about on what i'm
talking about but but i really love this
passage even as a young boy i loved
reading this passage and uh
uh just as like a
well okay so here's a personal anecdote
i probably shouldn't share on the
internet okay but uh when i would read
the story as a young boy i'd always
think i would like to be one of those
seraphim that's what i want to be i want
to just always be there right at the
throne of god always close to god just
like
that's what i wanted um
and then when i was received into the
orthodox church i was received with the
name seraphim and so
that's always been uh
uh so there's something really special
about this passage to me definitely
um
so the the christian tradition the
entire church has has uh understood this
passage along with very similar passages
in the apocalypse of saint john as being
the paradigm
of heavenly worship right so in the
story of the feast
we see that the story of isaiah is sort
of put through the paradox machine that
is the incarnation right and so isaiah
goes to the temple to meet with god but
now
god is coming to the temple to meet with
his prophet yeah
um who's been waiting there for him
and the the church in our hymnography we
sort of tease out the eucharistic
implications of this feast so in
iconography we depict simeon in the
attitude of someone about to receive
communion he's got he's got his hands
sort of yeah he's covered his hands yeah
and uh and of course the when the priest
or the bishop when they take communion
at the altar they repeat
basically the prayer the the words of
the seraph they say you know see this is
touch your lips your iniquity's taken
away your sin is purged
and in some medieval western churches in
spain especially
in the uh apps of the church which means
in the
in the holy place the holy of holies you
would often have an image of isaiah
with the angel and holding the tongs to
his mouth
um in the in the space where where the
the mysteries were were celebrated so
yeah you can see that the people that
the relationship with communion was
strong for all over the place yeah and
so one of my favorite examples of this
is in the canon of the feast um and
actually in general
the the the canons of the great feast
there are so many of them for instance
uh tomorrow's is the canon for the feast
of the annunciation uh which i'll
actually be reading in church tonight at
uh at the cathedral which i'm very
excited about because
the candidate of the annunciation is an
extended conversation between gabriel
and mary that's the whole canon
you know and she's like well you know
last time an archangel came to a woman
and promised her something it didn't go
so well so like i'm trying to be a
little careful here and and so he's like
reassuring her you know and it's just so
i mean it's so beautiful
um i think that if you wanted to
um
let's say like increase your devotion or
really sort of get to know the mother of
god like that's that's an important
service to be there for uh but in this
canon uh in the ninth odi mountains
there's this extended conversation
between jesus and simeon and anna and
the mother of god
and jesus says it is not the old man who
holds me
but i uphold him
for he begs me to let him depart and
then simeon says to the theotokos o
mystical tongs so now she's the tongs
right right
how dost thou bear the coal
how doest thou feed him who gives food
to all
and uh so so again you know the uh
and then and then we we
you know in the same candidate says
simeon the priest and of course the
priest is somebody who would normally
serve communion right
the simi and the priest received the
lord of all come down from heaven right
so there's just all these beautiful
paradoxes going on here so in isaiah's
vision he comes to the temple and comes
face to face with lord of hosts the king
and he's overwhelmed by his own
sinfulness with his own deadness of
spirit so a live coal something alive
something on fire is brought to him from
off the altar to cleanse his lips and to
make him pure
simeon on the other hand wastes the
temple and the lord of hosts thy
salvation the light to be revealed to
the nations and the glory of thy people
israel comes to him he's born like the
live coals uh uh like a life coal on
that on the tongs that are the theotokos
and then simeon's response is now i can
die
like isn't that
yeah so um and of course obviously in
our preparation for communion in the
orthodox church we pray
not to be consumed by fire right that is
the body and blood of christ but to
receive christ into ourselves to worship
him and this is the final for us as
christians this is a final consummation
st maximus the confessor says that those
who partake of communion in a worthy
manner are rendered similar to the one
who is good as the cause of everything
that is good and they are lacking in
nothing
so that even they are able to be called
gods by adoption according to grace
because the whole of god fills them
with himself
and leaves nothing in them empty from
his presence
so this is kind of my um
uh long answer to should christians
celebrate hanukkah and my answer is
something like no we should celebrate it
four times yeah right and but it's
beautiful because if you look at the
structure there are so many things going
on yeah you know when you think of if
you if you think of the first set up
that we talked about where you have
the
where you have the setup of the dark
space or the the holy of holies the
altar
is set up in this darkness and this
question then down comes the glory of
god hidden at the outset on the ark of
the covenant and then there's you can
imagine almost really like the priest
comes out
with the with the communion chalice out
of the holy place and then
reveals the light everybody sees now you
know here's the christ coming out of the
water and you know the the the voice of
god telling everybody this is this is it
like this is my son
and then it ends with the temple itself
or the big temple
uh acknowledging saying yes like we
recognize this we recognize that this is
what's happened so it's almost like the
reaction of of ana
and the priest is saying amen like this
is true this is happening so you have
the you have the the revelation of the
divine logos and then the reception from
the church and so it really is a
beautiful cosmic image of light and even
just like i like how light works you
know you the light comes down reveals
something and then you recognize it
and you you see what it is you see what
it is in in its form so it's it's all
the way down in the microcosm to our
small experience of you know you're
standing in darkness you turn on the
light you see something and you
recognize it this is there in
the very structure of these four feasts
and i mean that at that moment when the
chalice is brought out what do we say
you know god is the lord and has
revealed himself to us blessed is he who
comes the name of the lord and actually
there's some arguments for why that
could be better
translated the lord is god in other
words the lord kirios which is the greek
form of yahweh yahweh is god right the
god of israel that's god
and now he's revealed himself to us
right
and that's what these four feasts are
really about it's about this revelation
so you've got the entrance of the
theotol goes into the temple where the
ark of god returns the temple and it
foreshadows and sets the stage for the
restoration of the worship of the one
true god right and then the nativity we
see
the cave becomes eden
the cosmic temple and the image of man
is raised up and renewed
and then
theophany we've got the dragons of the
water being crushed and christ the light
illumines the cosmos with the light of
his triumph
and then this culminates in the meeting
of the lord in the temple when it
becomes possible for us to not only meet
god but to receive him
of course that ends with the
foreshadowing of the passion right the
sword will pierce your heart also
and so we see the whole purpose of the
old testament scriptures and prophecies
fulfilled which foreshadowed his coming
so um so yeah that's kind of i think the
winter feast of the church are really
beautiful and
it makes christmas longer
you know which what what more could you
ask for than that right
yeah
so this is great i mean i think it's
it's also i think a lot of these these
um
little these interpretations we're
giving is to give people a taste of
what's there because there's so much
there that you can't exhaust
in these talks and so it's i think it's
up to all of us to
to go back into our our traditions and
and and see the the beauty and the the
coherence that's there and these in
these uh feasts and in the text
themselves so and something that if
people want to take the universal
history connection a little bit farther
kind of with all of this in mind
something that's really good to do is to
go back and look at the tradition that
you're in and see
how was this celebrated i mean for
instance again in this book which i'll
just recommend one more time the
stripping of the altars
um there's a great section early on in
the book it's in the very first chapter
uh looking at
two things in specific in in england
before the reformation candlemas the
celebration of candlemas
which obviously we spent a lot of time
talking about so if you want to see how
was this celebrated in merry old england
you know
um
and then also holy week passion week
which was
can i just say
pretty awesome
in england before the reformation uh it
was also a lot more
um if you've if you've ever been to
orthodox holy week
and then you read his description of
what was english holy week like before
the reformation they're so similar
that if you were comfortable like if you
were already like sort of used to one
you would be very comfortable in the
other one there are
some interesting local differences but
they're very very similar uh so our the
you know the celebration of holy week in
the west has been
over the decades even recently has been
extremely truncated but uh it used to be
a lot longer and a lot more similar to
what we still do in the east so maybe go
back and look at those things and uh
it's like sort of digging up these
pearls of a beauty from your own
tradition that that you know maybe
you've lost touch with so yeah
so everybody this is you know what
there's so many of these that we will do
we're going to continue on and and uh as
len continues so i wish you a fruitful
lent
and uh and we i don't know i think did
we i don't know if we're going to see
each other before before pasca we'll see
no no thanks for your attention richard
thank you again for your scholarship and
your passion and we'll talk again very
soon thanks jonathan
this episode is part of a series of
discussions i've had with richard roland
on universal history you can find a list
of all these episodes on my youtube
channel where you can find them also in
my podcast stream from the symbolic
world on your different podcast
platforms make sure to check out
richard's second podcast which he hosts
in collaboration with father andrew
damick called amman sewell which looks
at the relationship between tolkien and
orthodoxy this podcast has also inspired
me some ideas for creating some images
whether it be the king under the
mountain whether it be the grail
or beautiful ethiopian traditions i've
created some products which you can find
on my store the symbolicworld.store
and there will probably be more of those
to come very soon so stay tuned this
conversation is ongoing and there is
still very much to explore in the
universal history